we're back oh what's up don't show me
boots
on the game
i guess
oh part three thank you crain oh
randall
all right goodbye margaret nope yes
okay we are moving on teleport
you just gotta go to the map i think oh
yeah that's right i keep doing this too
right yeah yes
oh lord
i see margaret kicked your ass
i've been
testing you what with margaritas see
whether or not grace truly does guide
you
and
whether you are fit to face the
challenge that entails i don't feel like
you get so there's
there's more
okay another thing you can take and lift
your face
gathering place i can take you to the
round table pizza
guided okay
you go to whatever that is
it's an arena filled with bosses okay
touched a girl you put your face in her
hand
oh
nice to meet you i am crandall
all right cool what are you [ __ ] sad
hello
combat is prohibited on the premises due
to impact of non-aggression oh no
it's located outside of this wall they
can only reach to the side of grace
through sights of grace
okay
so this is like it's a hub world but you
don't have to level here you can use
chill
cool
i wonder if like blacksmith or no no we
have the
the anvil
is this just like a co-op like
social media
oh my god
trevor belmont
rubbing your arm i'm rubbing a dog
a young woman named
he kind of looks like a less hot version
of myself
i think you're hotter i think so too
yeah
um okay did he just why
just told you about these missing
servants can you climb in the fire and
get in there
are you a statue or a person oh you're a
person that's quite a stance i have to
[ __ ]
help me i can't move
i can't remember the last time a new
tarnish made their way through that's
not how i would expect him to look at
his cool stuff things yeah
i bet you
yeah we get you're all safe tell me this
hand won't let go of me oh my god
i've been stuck here for a millennia my
hands been stuck in this cloth okay
and then who are you oh there's a
chandelier in there
oh you need help with that
oh it is like world of warcraft where
you have each class has its own little
trainer oh a man of the cloth
yeah are you
exhausting their dialogue is that
something in the darkspawn a lot or like
you have to talk to someone like six
times explore the secrets of the golden
order
so that one day
if a tarnished of the round table holds
ooh
you would be my counselor fellow man of
the blindfold
do you still see there's gonna be a
little bit of a problem with us okay we
just talk to people right now
do i still see it the guidance of grace
yeah i see it
like that okay oh
okay so it is kind of like
oh yeah because that was the other thing
about friendly trend was that
all your
mages and
everything
all your progressions yeah
i mean at least historically faith is
mostly just like heels and yeah but who
knows oh there's pyromancy too oh
there's fire
yeah this is just a different version of
the same menu i think
yeah yeah it's always all and then the
different categories categories okay
oh we know you're here good to know
all right i'm going to treat it like a
real round two fingers
be sure to tell me if you meet a young
woman named lanya that's his name he's
seven
she's bought my companion since
childhood i've lost counter the number
of times i've had to find her like this
you just ask people about it she's such
a little tomboy
it's a little weird what does that have
to do with her disappearing wait was
there any or had he already said that no
no a word of advice
as your senior
you are a mere visitor to the rounds
oh nothing more
a house guest
[ __ ] [ __ ] we fought market and lost
several times
yeah just going this way i'm treating it
like a real round table
oh no okay
go back are you ready for three fingers
oh i'm ready to go
edit that out edit that out you didn't
just
all right i'll dangle from that
chandelier
dude what if i could what's this this
place looks like a big wait did it
disable attacks like if you can't even
do anything
you can still destroy that's good that's
why the senior is mad at me yes and
you'll keep because you can't roll in
how do i run hold
i love that we don't
use stamina yeah that's great
all right who was this fine fellow
oh there's all of his reading books and
materials dominance by doing that before
i talk to people
why are you crying back then
oh cool
what do you want to do do you have to do
it against a wall
only one way to find out um how to go to
the right
and then switch yeah
and it is uh
it is this left one uh-huh
and then we're gonna okay
can you go back now just say
[Music]
look at that
it's even better without
wonder how big this place is yeah i mean
it feels lodge
oh
oh oh hello
are you alive
yes
okay twin maiden husks okay they are
indeed whoa
some vipins and amma
and some pictures too what's the aid of
a hunter that's cool
answers requests for somebody
increases memory slots oh for more
spells
used to break one imp statue
oh yeah i'm curious to see what this
stuff is
oh yeah they're really cool well
that was usable at the starting area
right yeah that's true i think we have
the the grace that's like right there
yeah and we have one key we can use
offer
should i
uh we might not have one but
okay try again
yeah very scary sexy oh thank you one of
the same
okay that's in here
have you tried resting at the table
resting at the table the round table
sorry i should have specified in this
room full of
buildings
um yes i was avoiding it because i
thought that it would like oh okay
somewhere yeah so let's just explore
first
good thinking good thing exhaust all
options
nice
i'm
fairly certain that you're going to meet
other people in the world and then
they'll end up
yeah you're probably right oh room you
haven't trashed
not for long
he's like barnacle andre yeah that's god
pirate man
what have you to say
um do we have anything that we actually
even can do
um
i think we use both our smithing stones
so i'm not sure
that sword is real strong now yeah at
least against normal enemies and not big
markets
can you do anything on the shield with
the edges anymore
no okay we don't have anything yet
negative actual duplication
hmm what would that do
can you only apply it to different
weapons yeah maybe you can only have it
on one weapon at a time or something no
doesn't really too much into it well no
grudge against you yeah all men
tell you there is no fault of yours wow
that's interesting inside
my own mind smithing
is
i like him yeah i like his barnacles
crusty back
[ __ ]
i don't think that'll work i would
suggest just ignoring them tries to
grab your face oh break your pancakes
oh bummer
hello pretty lady
you want to play just always wants back
you love eldon ring
the wine cellar oh this is really good
looking yeah they got some meat down
here
that's me jacob you love me i love meat
those shells gotta go
[Music]
oh it's an imp shrine
yeah stick your stone key in there let's
do it
oh
okay oh these chairs are going for sure
there's treasure in here oh my god
not anymore your son's [ __ ] okay okay
that was another one whoa
this goes deeper and deeper interesting
i'm guessing that door that was barred
from the other side will eventually
oh
krampus is crossbow
it's cradles crossbow now oh you think
it will loop back to that yeah it's not
interesting there's gonna be more and
more treasure as we go oh yeah there's
another one in there it's gonna be a
little
secret boss action
we only have one sword right yeah that
was the only one
do not leave this room undestroyed
i'm sorry yeah
take a nap what are you doing
okay i wonder if that's everything don't
give any guys
i know it's cutesy oh my god i thought
it was gonna hit you yeah it's a bad
idea to like give them what they want
but it's real hot not too much there we
go
hello
oh great finger butt hole
[Laughter]
is it because she knows
we'll take it she just wants to hold you
oh she wants your lively figure
and you're stout heartedness
this is a trap for sure
my thanks
great champion
it's just like
hardcore cutscene
she holds on her witch's hands
oh
oh it is
okay she'll give me some sort of
blessing when i'm visiting
my palms as awesome as you guys i think
i have a girlfriend i think you do it's
that easy huh
okay oh she's not letting you go though
all right all right break it up
literally there's a toy right there why
are you chewing on paper
well that was uh romantic okay it's fine
um all right
i wonder what it did
yeah
i wonder if it like lasts
forever temporarily she said it was cold
the dressing tale cosmetics
is perfect well you can change
everything yeah but we don't need to
never oh maybe
no oh yeah if you change the body type
it all goes away yeah no i would never
oh yeah
think that's a close one that's a close
one what's the name now krampus
that's just evolving
um okay back to the round table get them
all yep let's
slap our heads on that round table those
swords look awfully large
okay it's just a big one all right we're
just gonna leave
i guess so
i pause time
just take a little time
right that's a nice clock okay that's
[Music]
oh
that's weird that you have to
yeah go wherever you want now come back
here
and then head out this way yeah sure is
that a lake though yeah maybe go down
around around the back yeah yeah oh i
probably should have gone inside the
cave i'm just gonna get out of it that's
fine yeah whatever i want to go on that
bridge that's a shadow of a colossus ass
bridge yeah it is
oh yeah we're back yeah oh yeah
we're gonna redo that all right just
come out here there's just like a little
ramp out isn't it
no oh yeah i think you have to go all
the way around
nope
i'm gonna do that so many times
there we go
whoa these loading screens are so
enticing i know
i want to see these places stop copying
me
there's this thing that i keep hearing
you say that i'm like i will not adopt
this because i can adopt the way people
speak really easily you keep going hell
yeah
all the time yeah yeah yeah i've done
i've been doing that ever since i've
known john i will not do it and i can't
stop i must remain a dependent from the
people in my vicinity
who eagles killed
your big sword
[ __ ] oh
it looks cool over there oh is that the
r2 yeah yeah there's another big cute
click i think you can charge up our
two's in this
that's a chocolate that's bigger there's
more eagles to die
oh one of the australian
rat dogs or whatever i'm sorry young man
take your bones those brittle buns
just mind their own business
not allowed which they never do wow it's
not very realistic eagles are garbage
birds oh yeah yeah jacobs talks about
this pretty sick yeah i think when we
were in alaska somebody in the car was
telling us that like all the ball
there's so many bald eagles and they
just go through the trash really yeah
giant they are the one of the least
majestic birds yeah i feel like we did
that to them they were probably super
cool back in the day yeah you just
turned them into trash monsters yeah
just like us like why do we need to hunt
when we could just dig through like
mcdonald's
wait why do we have a oh we have some
moccasins
there's there he is oh you're steed
don't forget your steed yeah that's
gonna be
this is down on the d-pad over and over
down down down there
it's
square all right
neat
okay oh as well as bats i mean there's
no fall damage with our boy right i have
no i couldn't
so it seems like your horse and you are
separate there's also a bug in this
fight too yeah if your horse takes
enough damage then you'll get knocked
out yeah yeah
what does this [ __ ] bug think he is
nice it's easy to get her bug wildly
swing
yeah i mean how else do you got a horse
back
and then l1 and r1 do you eat either
side oh
oh that's cool
what is this bug where is it
come on you stupid [ __ ]
just run okay so we got like a
swamp situation going on here which is
always a little bit of anything to
village
not look like it
i like another little splayed out
spread eagle i got a bad feeling about
this swamp yeah
a little bit nervous was the dark souls
3 of the giant crabs in it yeah i don't
think i ever fought one i was too scared
dude they're
they're uh they'll gang up on you
okay oh look a turtle
rude it's just like a
tube of holes in it
is gonna explode what the hell was that
flying dro oh my god
fight it
into battle
okay
onwards stay shot
oh boy
who was if you said you think there will
be a dragon
i think i was talking to you and i was
like you think i think i asked if this
would be a dragon on bridge oh yeah
you're taking on bridge oh you got this
you got this oh you so got this yeah
let's keep moving
the ankles
it's actually not super easy to hit
turns out
but i don't want to get
oh
[Music]
this isn't what i was expecting for the
swamp no i expected something more
swampy
that's so cool look how cool he is
oh yeah
nice he did some good damage when each
hit when they land yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god jeez
okay look at that guy that is the most
that's the scariest thing i've ever seen
tear drops scarabs
okay
well um
all right so the swamp has a dragon the
swamp has a dragon in it good to know
and what was that when it landed it
killed like 12 things below the ground
there was like yeah it killed every
there was this little like group of
people standing around that all died
yeah there's like a bonfire it landed
yeah i think it just squashed all of
that i looked at it as though it came up
oh did it i don't know it could be wrong
i don't know guess what's fine again oh
he's just chilling down there now i
guess we'll never know
well
anyway good day to you sir yeah
not yet hello
and after
when you're safe we're going to equip
that crossbow oh yeah that's probably
actually full biting piece yeah you're
also left on the d-pad to get your
shield back
out here
yeah there are three slots
staying back all right
they're trying to eat the bugs that
things just do super sonic yeah it did
damage yeah a little streak a little
pokemon move
those are zubits zubats and goal bats do
you think that the crossbar will help
with mom grip
uh
no don't do it don't jump
you have so much left to live for
wow
i wonder if you can follow it forever
like your breath of the wild i think it
goes back to its wife oh yeah and kids
did you chase them
yeah
that was always annoying because you'd
shoot them once and you'd be like i'm
gonna get you yeah you be chasing them
and then they just fade into the ether
keep getting stuck on them there's gonna
be some items underneath these cliffs
for sure
whoa look at the yards
i'm sorry guys we're going to 4am for
sure
all right we got more bats or something
yep
i will take i will take the tiny dragons
of the large dragons oh okay
yeah okay
did oh god all you have to do is not get
hit yeah which like
you could maybe dude that's the
basically the philosophy
don't get hit just never get hit
that's why everyone does like all those
no hit runs every single person yep not
just that one guy yeah very easy to do
when you're jumping in someone has
successfully done no hit runs okay oh
yeah that dude so he did the trilogy and
now he does the six legend where he does
demon souls dark souls 1 2 3
bloodborne and sakura all known hit runs
yeah
but he doesn't do him in chronological
order i think he starts with sakura
because it's the hardest yeah i think as
long as there are games where you can
take damage there are people who will
attempt to know
puppy
oh who do you think you are oh
look like rocks they're so furry or
something i don't know that's so
textured they got something grown on
them oh oh look friends there's like a
little block party they're weak friends
yeah they're sure yeah they look all
sickly you can kill them
they gotta touch it
okay
they got dogs
they can't fight yeah i mean this is a
good indication of how much better the
sword is though he's just hiding he's
just awesome
that looks like my first dog they're
like
yeah they're like fully like like tiny
white dogs yeah upscale just big and
stinky
oh what's magic
let's go what'd you get for us we got
our favorite sword in the first one yeah
this seems deeper okay oh
there's some rats in here
all right let's smooth that rat
i wonder if that's right
okay at least they don't do poison
oh god oh god
oh god they're strong
it's fine oh i don't i don't know what
the button is to heal oh oh you got to
press down and then square and that's
why i accidentally pressed
right i think
to try to cycle dig rats that's a bit of
a shame which one should i go to the
shake the stick
and then we shall go
back to the rat dungeon surely there's
treasure in there surely a giant rat
won't appear that looks like bad
news okay there has to be some sort of
shadow of colossus type box
yeah we're on the horseback or something
yeah
hello
welcome to our domain i did
okay poor guy all right they do fight
they all deserve to die now
one of your friends killed me you must
all die you have shown hostility to
crumble or what was her name
changes
everybody called
and you must die it's scrambled this
episode
it's cool though that the stakes are
always kind of just wherever it was
close yeah to your like last thing
trina's living
if there's any like sort of
uh like game to it i guess that wasn't
with the dragon but that was close
yeah like if you go in anywhere
or if there's any sort of character
oh
they're a little scottish they're really
awesome yeah they got the big money they
got the big face
oh my god it's so cute
my favorite video game dogs i always
felt bad about it too with the ghost of
sushi my dogs yeah oh yeah they're very
cute
when they bark they sound like the house
moving castle dog
uh wasn't
uh yes it was like
oh for jumping attacks you it's only r2
oh really special yellow
down or jumping
they've always had that same attack
animation
yeah throwing themselves at you
the bark and then the throw yeah bark
bark bark these ones are the cues
i like them
from the front yeah when they fall over
on their side and you see their
mangy rib cage
okay
[Laughter]
do you want to see our underside
disgusting like a startup
[Laughter]
i wonder
in the bloodborne dlc they'll cower and
then attack you
oh yeah [ __ ]
fish
i don't even know what it is like for
the fish people the bloodborne dlc oh
god it's the worst place ever
hey oh
nice thanks
get out of my face
because you killed the horde you got a
heel back oh that's right it did say it
would do that okay um
oh we're chilling somebody else died to
rats
fine okay let's read it all right this
is probably good i should also do it
oh i didn't expect
that's all treasure awesome
little mini dungeon okay yeah yeah
oh
what the [ __ ]
uh oh
where do i go oh oh
wait we found a oopsy where you take me
look at the little pot guy oh my god i
would die for him i can't wait to find
him he's stuck i think they found
because it was in a trailer or like the
gameplay overview where you find him and
you have to like kick him out of a holy
stuff yeah
but uh someone in the network test found
that exact place but he wasn't there oh
okay
so we couldn't find it
yeah
what is this treasure
[Applause]
oh
because this is a random [ __ ] that'll
happen it didn't give you the option
to go back but maybe we just got back in
the dungeon
i don't know we'll see maybe oh yes
this is all an experiment for us
yeah i mean that's the whole game i
think guys cop in our style with that
mustache yeah that's true let's beat
them up
let's kill him he will be our next okay
here we go get the treasure
gravity stone fan what the [ __ ]
cool
those might be consumables like he
throws
that should i oh i can't
check because i feel like
put that like
there he is
just him they're all a whole bunch of
them
they're all working away
this looks like uh
oh my god we bit strong okay
okay this is just where you are now huh
it is yeah it fisheries oh okay
they might be able to shoot ranged
attacks out of there that guy oh it's
definitely that dude giant spear
definitely oh my god look at all these
limbs if you want to equip the crossbow
oh god are those legs
although i think those have a dex
requirement
generally
yeah oh
he's going forward
oh god oh god it hurts you're back in
the house
oh he's a freak what the [ __ ] he's a bug
man oh it's disgusting
uh they were in consumables
back to the first there you go
we made it
no this is the first window
uh
x
whoa
jacob
hmm
a shard of rock found in the wake of a
meteorite strike oh it is imbued with a
particularly weighty magic uses fp
to emit gravitational shockwaves
you should do it the deaths are all
desperate ones who scavenge for these
shots dubbed themselves stop
so that's who we're fighting we're
fighting star callers
oh look at the same thing
oh nice so that's basically just a
grenade
okay that's awesome yeah
environment we have to use some of these
you can equip it in the menu
which would be in equipment yeah and
then down the bottom of the walls
okay right with those boards oh that's
right yeah getting the ui
um this one so it does use focus points
too yeah but you know yeah throw some
gravity grenades okay oh yeah and then
to
uh
down down and then yeah
oh god
i'm so scared you got this watch out for
the bug boy
look out for those webs
it's like a
world 2 and dark demon souls
think maybe if you lock on it'll throw
it yeah i think now we actually
yeah oh boy that's gross
too many arms yeah you blocked his
attack before
i on i un ah
[ __ ]
yeah i think we need to be higher up
than him that's gross
oh
oh he's so creepy ooh yucky
[Laughter]
he looks like there's a giant isopods
yeah in the ocean i want more of the
item but they're in a chest it's not
gonna happen
yeah
you killed that guy pretty fast though
yeah you could take the other one do you
think you can do his dropping strike on
that guy probably you get him on that's
another one he's shooting at you he is
shooting at me that would be a and rt
oh jim yeah yeah yeah
okay this is so pretty yeah
very deceptive how dangerous it is okay
um
you gotta aggro this [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] christ
there we go you could [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Applause]
is anyone aggregate on you or like he
can't see you no i don't think so you
should let's check crafting and see if
we can heal like do have any [ __ ]
fairies or something
yeah make some meat
oh those are for feeding our horse oh
it's for horses like golden
like stopwatch
fingerprinting reveals co-op and hostile
something signs about our wolves
oh your little fire make some fire pots
i could do some bulbs oh can i make fire
pots i think i saw that it was grayed
out but you can't uh wolves is
available
oh we used our fp yeah and i removed all
the flasks
are there any items that restore fp that
we have in our inventory
i think the bug i kind of forgot
no sorry it would be in the first those
are all the consumables
what is that blue thing
oh
no [ __ ] gentleman uses always oh
damn it i'll use that we could try to
use this one throw some kukris at them
yeah
nope that's right
and then x removes let's do this
yeah there we go
okay so this one's a gravity wave so it
comes out of you
you can get a jumping attack on oh
okay you pissed him off
who did that you i bet you could finagle
a
jumping attack from up here if you just
drop down spin around
he does yeah
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that's gonna do some from the box god
okay um so should i just try this thing
how much fp do we have yeah yeah you
should just try it um yeah see what it
does don't echo that kind of thought
just
do it over there throw it i think it
comes out of you it's like a blast okay
let's try it
yeah watch out that weapon's going
through the floor
oh
it's strong
whoa
holy [ __ ] i feel like we're gonna regret
wasting these you only can only do it a
couple more times though with your fp
it looks like yeah
i think you should use it on him though
i don't know how to approach this
i think yeah i have to get the jump on
him right because yeah he sees me when
you hit those guys from above so you can
probably throw one more down oh no i
don't know if i hit him is the problem i
don't think he did
but those guys are everywhere so jump
down turn around use the thing down turn
around all right oh
okay
oh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
one more he's stuck
oh
that's a gross asset a [ __ ] does he
have a shell for a head
probably he may do yeah i don't know
that i don't i think we have to fight
our way out of here i don't even leave
yeah it keeps spawning you back in oh i
guess you could fast travel
more can you
did we get any food oh i missed a call
from my grandma
oh oh she's not as important as eldon
right
she might be playing now grandma
yeah
okay you still got 20 minutes left
[Music]
is there any indicator when you break
their stance or you just have to watch
for it i think there's a sound effect
and they'll fall there's like a
cool fan this is the one i can throw at
him right
no
they're going to feel like you're all
out of those
yeah
okay
can you get out of that roof going
around this all okay cool
oh [ __ ] about that
okay
i don't feel good about this
where did he go he's still up there yeah
okay
he's did a cold jump
leave him low
i guess yeah i don't need to kill him do
i yeah
yeah let's take a take down this guy
first well i could maybe avoid both
yeah you might just want to just try
maybe is there something in that hut
that the other guy's on there's your
room there
oh he sees you
it might be worth going into that
building that that second guy's on yeah
you're right there could be more of
these gravity whatever
yeah
oh
my god a sniper
i did not think he'd be able to do that
what a [ __ ] all right
i'm gonna go grab the food okay
is that big dang turtle nickname turtle
big name belle turtle hi thanks for the
views john i appreciate that
time stamp that one
[Laughter]
make it get fine all that
all right
yeah we're just going to kill the second
one maybe
yeah if all else fails we'll just run
that time no you don't oh what the hell
this ass this is the only one that's
feeding yeah oh
i didn't mean to do that
i hit a tree by
accident did i do damage though he's
stuck in the house he is stuck in a
house i think you hit him with one of
them for sure i did not mean to do that
at all there's your rules at least
that's cool [ __ ] okay
i'm running i'm running i'm running i'm
running i'm running
success i can't believe we beat him how
about that yeah elana you got a boat
that was cool was there anything in that
house i got scared and left
i could drag her back
that's true oh look there's a thing down
there to rest at
[Music]
the vibes are okay okay yeah we got tofu
i got tofu
oh [ __ ]
looks like there was a breeze and it's
the dog wagging us
it is a big old tail ain't no so you
doggy
oh my god all these mexican codes
i can't really do anything
gary
hello sit
can you sit oh gosh okay
oh let's see
here
[Laughter]
yeah the wolves use like almost all of
the fpe but
because i rest
oh you rest yes
my first down on the d-pad
or wait how do you bring up your [ __ ]
health plans crap
really maybe when you attack it brings
it up no no i think that's a uh
well yeah because if you attack it
affects your stamina so was that a long
forks
so i should be out of some of the wolves
right
maybe you can't summon them in here in
here yeah yeah safe place [ __ ] up you
got forks downstairs yeah in the kitchen
yeah it is right
jacob can you bring me pepper towel yeah
there's also napkins with the actually
okay
what is this looks like secrets but i
guess it's not okay i accidentally
spammed all of the crystals
i thought it would use one they used all
three at once
oh really yeah okay
oh yeah stealth is a thing in this game
what is that you see that
yeah
oh it's one of those golden crystals
that they're mining
which
i was thinking
because there's some on the wall i
wonder if you hit them
they break something off
like those
oh he's gonna be up there right yeah
okay
oh
yeah should i leave probably yeah yeah
he's real worried about getting stabbed
to the back okay
not a super successful journey those
things i wasted was sick though we'll
find more of them somewhere
i'm feeling there's going to be a lot of
dope-ass consumables
so i could probably fast travel away now
right
but where am i
whole new area
whoa
was this
where is it oh my gosh
wow okay
we're like full corner of the map
whoa
oh that's gonna be terrible wait open up
the map again
you think that's the whole world map no
you don't think so uh-uh
maybe i mean it does look too small
doesn't it yeah yeah yeah you're right
this is just the border of this part of
the map
holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
crystal what's it face we came out and
this is where we were
there's a giant skull up there that i
bet you i walk in there and duck um you
should do it yeah only one way to find
out the dragon went so well yeah this
will go well too okay maybe this new
crafting stuff i mean you just got a
grace
yeah that's true who cares yeah
that looks good okay who's this
gentleman i think it's just one of them
big boys
you think same kind of big boy
yeah oh maybe not no that's a big snail
it is a big snail
oh oh you can fight them they're slow
yeah i could probably put it oh my god
they're everywhere i didn't even really
fight them there's still a little face
what yeah let's go peek it's got a
little like a little top bit
oh hello not that slow okay
yeah you can find them you got little
blow holes
yeah we'll say hi
oh it's spraying something yeah it sure
is oh something just flew past yeah
something is shooting oh people okay
okay oh oh my god
look at their cages it happened so fast
i just realized they were there and then
i was dead yeah oh god this might be one
of those areas huh
well i think i'd be fine to leave now
but yeah what if not leave maybe just
sprint across with your watch take
another look
yeah
let's explore
all right let's just walk and see what
happens can't wait to find out what i
got summoned through this
[ __ ]
swap level
get out of my face ui oh there's
something in the water hello oh it's
[ __ ] it's like jesus
what
oh
i'm saying geezers yeah i said it like a
british
okay what are you looking at are you
looking at something
bugs what
just it doesn't feel good to kill
somebody you know yeah
run around with anything
oh it's a little butt little butt bug
i think it's good
it's back yeah
one more hit one more hit
one more hit oh
excuse me
there we go
oh
they got something cool you got an
actual war
oh did i agree yeah it looked faithy
it's really good for my ego off of the
cake
oh that looks like an npc friend
are you sure about that oh yeah yeah
yeah but i'm probably going to sell you
something he has a health ball
um
yeah he's definitely gonna sell you for
sure gonna sell me something yeah
i'm just gonna keep moving if you think
about it we all have health bars so we
do we're just not visible yeah
oh items let's you should get those
how am i running
okay
what the
swamp man oh [ __ ]
is that ornstein oh maybe
all right i thought i would just like
uncover the map
you know what i'm saying
just scope it out see what's happening
like punch this dude in the back
i was so sure he'd have like a couple of
sword hits yeah we were so sure that
four of them was real bad so one of them
would be fine wow okay
um
we keep the map unlocked though right
hmm i'm curious about what i should do
here that's where i was what's this oh i
think you should find out
that's probably
um a little shrine or something yeah
like one of the strengths trying to see
what they look like on the map
no maybe it's not
they don't show up on that
i don't know what that is
but we're not really making helpful
progress by me doing this
is that we need the left the left the
xps
and we aren't getting it
um
i mean i can kill my bugs you're good
that's more grievouses no [ __ ] that
there's a building's over there to the
left
yeah let's approach this
big
snail guys
oh it's delicious it was a good burrito
but
they cut it in half and it was juicy
my whole concept behind the burrito was
to hold it
and not make a mess yeah and the
opposite happened yeah bowl is much
easier yeah messier than a bowl
oh great
is that a little salad
of seoul okay
okay he looks like a burger king mascot
he's kind of cute
you have a whopper
okay that's good
all right
i think you found the ghost library
there he is again
oh
no
oh my god
oh yeah some shields
do like no
magic walking
yeah that makes sense
the attacks were pretty slow though
yeah so dodgy yeah that's true i'm not
even trying to dodge anything which is
pretty dumb you can do that
but now i want to know what's in the
shack can we look at the shield stats
uh
okay yeah zero magic here open it up
what about the other shields
and then
no magic what about that big shield yeah
that big boy down below
no magic all right well cool probably
not equipped to go here oh no wait that
was damage
we were looking at the wrong one oh
you're right you're right i was also
looking at damage of course it doesn't
um
so fifty percent
so it's something
oh okay so that's the strongest one but
it's still only
you're still taking 45
where am i
hello burger king mascot
you addicted guys look at that easy
peasy
nice dodges
literally was
oh my god
magic shotgun he's got multiple faces
that's not fair
we didn't know which way it was facing
they didn't do that oh no i blocked them
i am burger king jack in the box and
toucan sam
oh my god okay
i wonder what we where we get the
materials
are the enemies just appearing in random
places god
jesus christ holy [ __ ]
no it's calm down you're okay
oh my god this is overwhelming
just like that
swampy area in dark souls 2.
before that frog singing frog
that guy's so cool the one that's just
like a big face
yeah inside of like a rubber suit
i
maybe try stealth for a few but i feel
like they just like saw me and then okay
yep and then just like spawned and
masked they have magic eyes
you just run for it
oh maybe i can record it
they don't seem to run at all [ __ ] hey
they just slapped you with their bibles
yeah
they'll be with you
they're really cool looking okay so they
don't all have multiple faces
do with that information what you will
well i think the multiple face one
had the strongest attack
um
the best smiles like you say run but
what am i running to
a little present
it's not going to go back over there i
guess
do that cave you get on your steed and
just run through oh yeah
there's so many enemies here yeah i feel
like there's probably some kind of item
you're supposed to get or something
maybe it's daytime or something oh
because it almost feels like this
morning
oh
is there a
grace gracefully i think just that way
wasn't there one i'm not sure but i
haven't what is this i've been this way
is this where we came from no
it took me to the closest what is this
steak where were we
i don't even know
oh we're just down the road from one
oh
yes follow the road let's see what
happens
i'm just trying to what is that on the
left
turn around turn around
oh
by the shack where is the shack i'd love
to stop by the shack oh my god
that was a real scare oh [ __ ] let's get
the [ __ ] out of me oh my god
i was looking up but like at the same
time
i thought it was a statue because it was
just there like this oh my god we got a
good look at it
is it did it run back just a big t-rex
dog yeah it was like t-rex dog it looks
like it looks like a pit bull oh look at
your feet so slow chicken boys it really
is a really special [ __ ]
what's this that's not a shack where is
the shack
anyway i guess
is he still coming
nah i think he went home
okay looks like one of the dogs from
like the angley hulk but he's facing us
is what's creepy about it that's the
only way you can walk is backwards with
those big legs
i'm gonna go get this item do it yeah i
can do it go back home
but maybe that's the shack
where oh that is the shack you're right
look at him he looks like a big dick
okay let's go to shaq look at his new
videos i mean i could try and fight him
he's just one guy
this is one guy yeah wants to go to
check look at the dog it does look like
a statue though yeah yeah
yeah yeah i saw his head from the side
for one hour if i saw that i would be
like let me go to the shack probably
just a statue
oh my god that is the weirdest thing
i've ever seen i love that character
design song look at his neck is there
something going on his neck uh i think
he just has a really long neck maybe
he's a collar you ain't seen [ __ ]
not doing a great job gonna have to use
the front door
you're also a good dog
you're a good dog too you know i don't
wish that i would never come from
another dog around you you're the best
dog hello
he's a friend
he is a friend
[Music]
great sage in my day anyway i'd hoped to
ask a favor when one of your ilk came
along
a strapping young todd a strapping young
garnish ah a little boy don't fret oh so
maybe he'll give us whatever we need to
deal with this [ __ ] to deal with general
grievous
oh the secret yeah yeah um
you know there is i would like to hear
it
are you i need your help to heal okay
never mind you know what talk about
[ __ ] i think we're just gonna have to
figure it out on her
you will find her beyonce and her beyond
celia
resting at the church atop the cliff
the rotting sickness that afflicts
millicent has no cure kill her when the
tree flourished even the demigods could
not stave off it's interesting
can be ameliorated what does that mean
for this you ought to find a meal you're
ready to find a needle
seek the deep scarlet swamp of aeonia
outside i've been there
the needle made from unarchived gold
this one's not that big
what are you gonna help me with the town
if you wanted people to come and help
you why did you put a [ __ ] massive
guard dog out there
just pick a real big barrier for entry
okay i so we can do that um i'm going to
try and kill the dog oh boy all right
see what happens
that's what his neck is
oh
oh he does not bad at all yeah
uh i keep forgetting with these games
and i keep doing it that you can't
interrupt something that you've done
so like when i was pressing the the x to
use that crystal thing i kept forgetting
and then i just did the same thing
um all right i will eat and we will pass
the controller
oh yes